Urine holds a lot of sexual secrets and while
humans simply flush it down a toilet… some
animals use it for seduction.
Porcupines are big fans of golden showers.
They bathe in the bounty of sexual cues in
this water sport.
You see, pee is a way to show off sexual prowess
and females are looking for a fire hose kinda
flow.
But timing is key.
Female porcupines are only fertile and interested
in sex for 8-12 hours per year!
The rest of the time, their vaginas are sealed
up by a membrane in order to stave off unwanted
action – as if having a body covered in
protruding spines isn’t enough.
During the short mating period, the female’s
vaginal plug dissolves, and an odorous mucus
begins to flow.
Ladies make a point of spreading their vaginal
mucus and urine around their territories in
order to attract nearby males.
You can imagine that when a male porcupine
detects the scent of a horny female, he’s
going to make his best effort to get some
sexual action.
Getting the girl doesn’t come without a
fight, so only the strongest porcupines get
the ladies.
The victorious suitor will take a position
about 6-8 feet away and douse his partner
with a powerful golden shower.
The urine stream is both forceful and abundant.
It’s meant to stimulate ovulation in the
female, and she’ll usually decide at this
point if the male is allowed to proceed with
copulation.
If it’s a yes, she will present her delicate
hind-quarters to him, and curve her tail around
her back so that the male won’t get impaled
on her sharp spines.
The male will then copulate as many times
as she will allow before heading off to find
another willing partner.
After all, he’s only got a few hours a year
to make this happen.
So he better hydrate and get on with it.
If you want to see more copulation creations,
check out this Wild Sex playlist!
Let us know in the comments what animal sex
stories you want to see.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!